this summer find out what happens when
the tape we've all been waiting for
finally hits the Internet one man two
women one motel 6 in Russia come on now
I'm down here okay you got gravity on
your side do what you gotta do
where do you want me to pee you know
what you do if I tell you where the
funds all gone okay
you do your thing you do it good many
people are saying you're terrific
okay so just be yourself when everyone
thought the tape couldn't exist it did
you know Here I am okay it was a lot
more than I thought quite frankly okay I
need to tell my hand tell moist if
preferable all right okay don't tell
Melania don't tell anybody you're
terrific you're tremendous many people
excuse me
very sad I love you Tony Danza is
Melania
a I heard there's a P tape baby is that
right
no there's not there's no such thing I'm
a germophobe that's crazy
okay that's crazy stuff but desert
people got crazy you said you love me I
don't love anything okay I love the way
my hair lays on my skull okay that's
what I love Michael Caine is Sarah
Huckabee Sanders listen there's no P
tape there's absolutely no pay tape I
know you got shaders or P tape there's
no P tape who keeps saying there's a PT
I tell you is is y'all fake news Paul
McCartney is that is the hotel manager
who found the P on the bed
Hulu is a beautiful mess up hairs you
know I'm not on the door there's nothing
you're golden with the maid scheme right
and it's just you know everything's all
wet and soggy so you know unless that we
go to clean it up we can't put someone
in here with his soda thing going on
Liam Neeson and Glenn Close as the
couple who was supposed to stay in that
room
now hows skills I've acquired in terms
of cleaning up urine that make me a
nightmare for our prostitutes such as
yourself if you leave now no harm will
come to you I'm not really angry but I
talk like this all the time and the
church lady as the woman who tried to
help Trump find himself after such a
horrendous adventure oh well well we've
got picadillo
don't we we've got little nasty habits
don't we well next time we'll have an
umbrella
okay mr. Trump you're right forgive me
God forgive me Jesus too late this
summer the movie we've all been waiting
for
Trumpy tape be there they said it
couldn't happen until it did it's about
last night